welcome back southwest medical is now
accepting
all medicare and its supplements at all
of their locations so i spoke to one of
the doctors
to get a further explanation here's our
conversation
so we're talking medicare just share
some of the basics of that for us please
so great question always kind of
complex and people sometimes have a hard
time understanding it
breaking it down there's really four
parts to medicare there's medicare a
which is the hospitalization coverage
that comes with medicare
part b which is your outpatient part
this is uh
maybe doctors is its outpatient
procedures diagnostics
part c which is medicare advantage and
that usually encompasses
a and b and then there's part d which is
your prescription
uh drug plans that medicare covers so
things you'd mainly get at the pharmacy
okay and who can actually get medicare
so medicare for for most it's going to
be at the age of 65
a u.s citizen or a legal resident who's
been in the united states for five
straight years also there are some
disabilities that will qualify people
early to be on medicare
and what are those enrollment periods
whether you're getting medicare or
you're already on it
each year there's what's called open
enrollment that's a chance for
each person because remember medicare is
an individual insurance
to look at the plan they have see if
it's meeting their needs
and if they need to make changes or
adjustments it's during that open
enrollment time which is usually
from october to december uh
that you can make those changes describe
some of the growth of southwest medical
how's it evolved in recent years
so as you're aware and probably a lot of
your
viewers are aware southwest medical has
been in the valley since 1972
and we've grown significantly we've gone
from a three physician
group to now where we have over 450
providers
that are part of uh southwest medical or
optimum care specialties
and new technologies as well like the
now clinic and new apps for people
absolutely the now clinic uh as uh
people have been uh bunkered in their
homes
being able to have video conversations
with their uh physicians has been going
is become more important we also
developed
medicine on the move which some people
in town may have seen it rolling around
the streets it's a
mobile clinic on wheels it has two exam
rooms a mammogram
x-ray can do immunizations really the
outreach to our
community and make sure everybody has
access to great health care
wow that's really cool and is there any
information or resources you can share
for medicare and i hear there there
might be medicare classes that make it
more clear for people
they are medicare classes and again i
think thank you for bringing that up and
it's very important
so what you have a number it's 1 800
medicare
and if you call that number they're able
to help you get into classes
and learn more about medicare understand
all the different options
because there are a lot make sure that
the options you're picking
best meet your needs and then we also
have a medicare made clear dot com
and if you go on that website you can
start searching it get into classes
learn more about medicare
and the different options will be best
for you
southwest medical has locations across
southern nevada for more information
call the number on your screen
or just visit their website smalv.com
you can also join us live today on the
eight news now facebook page at 4 30.
las vegas now will be right